en 1944 la France se libère de qure
longues années d'occupation les
collaborateurs sont devenus les hommes
his d'une France qui souhaite se
reconstruire au fil des années des
décennies la mémoire collective
simplifiera et schématisera les
engagements d'hommes et de femmes pris
dans les tourments d'une époque ambigue
et
incertaine ainsi la collaboration
restera invariablement associée à
l'extrême droite alors que la gauche
sera synonyme de résistance
mais l'histoire est complexe un nouvel
éclairage doit être apporté sur cette
[Musique]
période beaucoup d'hommes de gauche se
sont engagés dans la collaboration parce
qu'ils ont été aveuglés par leur
anticommunisme parce qu'ils ont été
aveuglés par le
[Musique]
fisme ce sont des gens qui disent on ne
va pas attendre une seconde guerre
mondiale pour tendre la main à
l'adversaire d'hier ce sont des gens qui
viennent de gauche qui ont passé une
mutation qui qui a fait deux des des
nazis et il deviennent l'extrême droite
sous
l'Occupation un peuple aime à se
conserver des zones entièrement
éclairées et des zones qui sont
entièrement des zones d'ombre mais la
notion de flux croisé est une notion qui
passe
[Musique]
difficilement tout commence lors de la
première guerre mondiale 4 années de
guerre terribles ont ravagé l'Europe et
plus particulièrement la France qui en
recessera jamais
[Musique]
meurtrie ce conflit où pour la première
fois la machine à écraser les hommes est
un véritable choc pour toute une
[Musique]
génération la Grande Guerre a été un un
très profond traumatisme pour euh la
population française bien entendu la
France sort victorieuse de cette épreuve
mais dans le même temps elle a perdu
énormément euh d'hommes hein 1,3
millions et donc du coup la la
sauvagerie la la dureté de de ce conflit
a nourri un très profond pacifisme la
société française qui incontestablement
a été patriote union sacrée dans sa
grande majorité en
1914 revient très profondément pacifique
et pour une élite
pacifiste ça se voit dans l'évolution
par exemple du Syndicat national des
instituteurs avant guerre l'instituteur
c'est vraiment le pat priote par
excellence républicain mais tricolor en
1918 19 beaucoup d'instituteurs vont
désormais être indéfectiblement
partisans de la paix donc le pacifisme
est absolument fondamental et il
s'identifie plutôt à la
gauche socialiste mais aussi
communiste ce pacifisme imprègne la
société française de l'entre de
guerre il se manifeste chez les anciens
combatt dont le créd est plus jamais ça
mais aussi par une littérature
prolifique où certains récits témoignent
de l'horreur des
tranché ce pacifisme trouve son
impulsion en politique au milieu des
années 20 en la personne d'arestide
brillant inamovible ministre des
Affaires
étrangères nous n'acceptons pas que dans
aucun cas pour aucune cause dans aucune
circonstance la guerre que nous avons
clouée au piloris comme un crime puisse
se réveiller contre
les arestide brillant devient d'une
certaine façon entre 18 et le début des
années 30 sa mort de plus en plus
partisan sinon de la paix à tout prix
dans tous les cas d'un rapprochement
avec l'Allemagne de la Société des
Nations et un futur collaborationniste
comme jeanlucher c'est vraiment
clairement un héritier d'arestite
brillant
[Musique]
c'est à la fin des années 20 marqué par
de bonnes relations franco-allemandes
qu'émerge la génération dite
réaliste Jean-Luc cher journaliste et
fondateur du journal notreetemp fait
partie de cette génération de jeunes
Français prêts à s'investir dans les
combats de la gauche pour le progrès et
désireuse de consolider cette bonne
entente avec
l'Allemagne jeanlucher est un
intellectuel de gauche il est ami de la
LIC participant certaines activités de
la Ligue internationale contre
l'antisémitisme en 31 32 et il développe
un pacifisme raisonné qui est fondé sur
l'idée que mon dieu il y a strictement
aucune raison que la France et
l'Allemagne continuent à
sentredredéchirer il établit un contact
avec un jeune démocrate allemand très
sympathique lui aussi partisan d'un
rapprochement entre la France et
l'Allemagne qui s'appelle auto abet et
ils établissent une espèce de structure
de rencontre qui permettra à des jeunes
des deux pays d'échanger leurs
impressions et puis de développer leur
commune volonté de de de paix le
personnage d'utabet est fascinant et
d'aurs il fascinera à l'époque beaucoup
de futur collabo parce que il est de ces
Allemands qui ont tendu la main aux
Français et auquel les Français ont
tendu la main avant Hitler à la fin des
années 20 au début des années 30 en 1933
moins d'un an après la mort d'Aristide
brillant Hitler et les nazis arrivent au
pouvoir en Allemagne
[Applaudissements]
pourtant à gauche on pense que la
réconciliation même avec une Allemagne
hyairrienne est encore
possible y compris des personnalités
comme Léon Bloom qui dans son journal Le
Populaire entretient cette illusion il y
a pas un article sur le réarmement
allemand en 33 34 et 35 dans le
populaire et il y a pas un article sur
le réarmement allemand parce que
l'obsession de la gauche est une
obsession pacifiste on veut pas faire la
guerre à l'Allemagne même hitlrienne on
dénonce le nazisme dans sa nocivité
contre les juifs ou contre la gauche on
ne veut pas dénoncer le danger que
représente une Allemagne qui réarme pour
la France et c'est ça qui va conduire
Léon Bloom à développer au fur et à
mesure que les nouvelles arrive selon
laquelle Hitler est en train de réarmer
l'Allemagne a développé des théories de
plus en plus fantaisistes du genre
l'Allemagne réarme alors il faut que la
France désarme pour créer une dynamique
de désarmement mondial et donc s'il y a
une dynamique de désarmement mondial
l'Allemagne pourra pas
réarmer pourtant non seulement
l'Allemagne serit réarmes mais la
répression politique et les persécutions
des Juifs se font désormais au grand
jour outre rein obligeant la gauche à se
positionner sur des principes de plus en
plus
[Musique]
contradictoire quelqu'un comme Lucher le
jeune Lucher
qui est un ami de la LICA un ami des
Juifs il dit c'est terrible ce qui
arrive aux Juifs ça choque notre
sensibilité ce qui arrive au juif en
Allemagne mais le vrai problème c'est de
faire la paix avec l'Allemagne
c'estàdire que dans cette gauche
pacifiste qui était à la fois
antiraciste et pacifiste il y a une
première rupture à savoir il faut
choisir on est hostile à l'Allemagne où
on est encore favorable au rapprochement
franco-allemand au cours des années 30
les partis politiques notamment à gauche
se
divisent les premières scissions sont
l'œuvre de deux hommes Marcel de figure
montante de LAF l'ancêtre du Parti
socialiste et Jacques Dorot le puissant
maire communiste de
Saint-Denis de ancien combattant de la
Grande Guerre marqué par son expérience
des tranché est un pacifiste viscéral
qui se distingue par ses prises de
position antifasciste tout au long des
années
30 intelluel agrégé de philosophie rondé
1933 avec Léon Bloom dont il ne partage
pas les conceptions
économiques il entraîne dans son sillage
d'autres socialistes comme le maire de
Bordeaux Adrien Marquet pour former les
néosocialistes don la devise est
désormais ordre autorité nation la
valeur des mots ordre autorité nation
cette manifestation de bon sensurait d
épouanter
personor ouvrier métallurgiste qui va se
iser au plus haut dans les instances du
parti communiste et quant à lui un
tribin cet homme de terrain orateur
capable de soulever les foules fut le
responsable des Jeunesses communistes
s'illustrant au cours des années 20 par
son anticolonialisme et son
antimilitarisme mais en 1934 il est
exclu du parti Jacques Dorot est un
communiste qui a eu le tort d'avoir
raison trop tôt il pense que il faut à
tout prix s'entendre avec les sociétés
pour faire un front commun contre le
fascisme or ce n'est pas la ligne de
Moscou Jacques Dorot son écarte de
manière un peu trop ostensible ce qui
fait qu'il est exclu du Parti communiste
français et un mois après la complète
rupture en mai 1934 le Parti communiste
adopte en fait
surcigne répété de Moscou une
perspective qui était celle que
souhaitait Dorio donc ça c'est
dramatique d'être numéro 2 incompris et
la dérive anticommuniste de d'Orio va
s'accélérer entre 34 et 36 le parti
auquel nous avons appartenu pendant
longtemps qui s'appelait le Parti
communiste a maintenant complètement
changé de politique quand à c'est le
golden boy du socialisme français
simplement il est convaincu que tout ce
socialisme est vraiment
poussiéreux abandonnons les références
marxistes et même la référence à un
syndicalisme de lutte des classes ceci
va donc amener Marcel DEA à se situer en
rupture par rapport au partis socialiste
qu'il quitte donc il n'a pas totalement
rompu avec la gauche mais il est clair
qu'il n'est plus dans l'orthodoxie
socialiste tel que l'incarne par exemple
Léon Blouin Jacques Dorot qui fond en
1936 un nouveau parti le PPF Parti
Populaire Français et Marcel DEA amorce
ainsi une l dérive politique qui les
éloigne progressivement de la
gauche leur mutation commencé dans la
seconde moitié des années 30 sachez sous
l'Occupation lorsqu'ils constitueront
une nouvelle forme d'extrême
droite en ma 1936 une foule en liè
acclame l'arrivée au pouvoir du Front
populaire ce nouveau gouvernement est la
promesse d'un avenir meilleur pour des
millions de Français qui profitent de
l'instauration des congés
payés pour la première fois est créé un
sous-secrétariat d'État au sport et à
l'organisation des loisirs
dans ce cabinet ministériel émerge un
jeune homme de 28 ans Marc Ogier
enthousiaste pour cette nouvelle ère qui
s'annonce et pourtant Marc Ogier c'est
un jeune militant des auberges de la
jeunesse journaliste il est le rédacteur
du principal périodique des auberges la
jeunesse de gauche le centre laïque des
auberges la jeunesse la responsable de
ce centre est une brillante
représentante de la bourgeoisie juive de
gauche et puis en 37 il le raconte
lui-même il va dans un café il ouvre le
bouquin un bouquin qui s'appelle La
Gerbe des forces qui est publié par
Alphonse de Châteaubriant Alphonse de
château-briant est un ancien
drachusard qui est devenu pacifiste qui
a fait un voyage en Allemagne
hitlérienne et qui est revenu enchanté
et pronazie et qui restera pronazie
jusqu'au bout et dans la gerbe des
forces c'est un livre où il raconte son
son son séjour en Allemagne hitlérienne
bouleversé par par par une Allemagne de
paix
par Hitler humain l'humanisme hitlerrien
les grands rassemblements c'est vrai ils
ont l'air un peu militariste ces
rassemblements mais en fait c'est des
rassemblements pour la paix
enfin
alon Mar raconte j'ai ouvert ce livre
j'étais dans un café à la fin de la
lecture à la fin de ce livre j'étais
devenu
naz en 1937 je n'étais qu'un petit
socialiste beta confond fondateur et
animateur du centre laïque des auberges
de la jeunesse plein de bonne volonté et
d'admiration pour Léon Bloom
entre et moi brusquement se dressa le
dernier livre d'Alphonse de
châteaubillant je me souviens
parfaitement de ce jour dramatique où je
l'ouvris 48 he plus tard j'étais devenu
national socialiste la mutation subie ne
m'effrayait pas répondit à
[Musique]
tout tandis que la France du Front
populaire vit une parenthèse enchantée
le trè Raich avance ses pions après
l'annexion de l'Autriche c'est au tour
de la Tchécoslovaquie d'être réclamé par
Hitler hanté par les perspectives d'e
nouvelle guerre les dirigeants anglais
et français finissent par plier face aux
exigences du fureur et signent les
accords de Munich en septembre
1938 accord de munique il faut le
rappeler sont votés par la gauche hormis
les communistes donc il est clair que la
gauche est plutôt favorable à munque
mais vous avez pourrait-on dire deux
types de munikois vous avez les muniois
qui au fond pense que la paix est sauvée
et que cette paix il va falloir la
sauvegarder à tout prix et c'est dans
une certaine mesure l'idée d'un pole
fort et puis vous avez les muniois de
raison qui pense que Munich est la
dernière concession que l'on doit offrir
au chancelier Hitler et que si après
Munich les intentions bellissistes de
l'Allemagne persiste il ne faudra plus
hésiter à aller au conflit et c'est la
position de Leon
bloua dans les mois qui suivent toutes
les formations politiques marquées à
gauche éclatent entre les partisans du
réarmement et Les
ultrapacifistes Paul Fort le numéro 2 de
la i fo se heurte à lon Bloom désormais
favorable
le parti se divise un tiers des
militants suivent pa
for c'est le cas de Charles spinas
députéf de la cor et ancien ministre de
l'Économie puis du budget sous le front
[Musique]
populaireme
sy minorité anommuniste de la CGT Suiten
anci agenttier etun respons syndicale
qui reste municois et partisan d'une
paix coûte que
coûte les pacifistes sont de moins en
moins nombreux mais ils sont de plus en
plus pacifistes les syndicalistes
postiers instituteurs René bin campent
sur le position et même au moment de
Munich c'est l'argumentation plutôt une
mauvaise pai qu'une bonne guerre quoi
donc faut bien voir que la France qui
entre en guerre en 39 est complètement
démentibulé aucun parti politique n'a
résisté à la montée des périls et Munich
annonce à peu près les clivage
c'està-direen dehors des communistes
vous pouvez photographier la situation
politique de la France au moment de
Munich vous avez les futurs résistants
les futurs cab là c'est c'est clair la
gauche non marxiste vient d'éclater sous
le coup des accords de
Munich le 23 août 1939 c'est autour des
communistes l'Allemagne nazi et l'Union
soviétique signent un Pact de
nonagression dans lequell des clauses
secrètes prévoient l'invasion et le
partage du territoire polonais entre les
deux
puissances cette alliance contre nature
déchire le Parti communiste français qui
de fait devient indirectement allié de
l'Allemagne Marcel Giton le numéro 3 du
parti comme de nombreux camarades finit
par rompre avec l'appareil les mois
suivants en 1939 ce qu'on donne comme
consigne à un bon communiste c'est
d'accepter le pacte Louis Ragon va
chanter les louanges du pacte et par
conséquent la fidélité à l'appareil et à
l'Union sovitique sétique au moment du
pacte germano-soviétique est
véritablement considéré par les
dirigeants du Parti communiste français
comme la pierre angulaire l'épreuve avec
un E majuscule qui permet de voir qui
est véritablement fidèle sur qui on peut
véritablement s'appuyer et qui ne l'est
pas l'invasion de la Pologne par
l'Allemagne nazi et l'Union soviétique
en septembre 1939 conduit le
gouvernement d'aladier à déclarer la
guerre au 3è rachche mais aussi à
dissoudre le Parti communiste qui refuse
de dénoncer l'agression
[Musique]
soviétique après plusieurs mois
d'inertie les troupes nazi finissent par
attaquer à l'ouest le 10 mai 1940 et
pénètre en France quelques jours plus
tard partout c'est la
débacle le chef du parti communiste
Maurice Torz tenu par sa fidélité au
pouvoir soviétique a déserté l'ARM
française pour rejoindre
Moscou on relève même des actes de
sabotage dans les usines d'armement
contre les forts de guerre
[Musique]
français le 14 juin les troupes
allemandes entrent dans Paris le drapeau
nazi va flotter sur la capitale pendant
qu longues années c'est l'occasion pour
le parti communiste interdit en France
de tenter de sortir de la
clandestinité
quelques jours plus tard sur ordre de
Jacques Duclot le chef du parti
communiste clandestin un haut dirigeant
du parti et de militant se présent dans
les bureaux de la commandantour à Paris
pour faire reparaître l'humanité
interdit depuis plusieurs
mois les Allemands ne s'y opposent pas
mais c'est le tout nouveau gouvernement
de Vichi qui proteste auprès des
autorités d'occupation pour empêcher sa
reparution vous imaginez quand même
symboliquement France si l'humanité
avait reparu ne serait-ce que deux trois
numéros donc là au sein du parti
communiste il y a de toute façon un
débat et assez vite des consignes de
prudence sont envoyées même par Moscou
mais la démarche de ces militants assez
élevés dans le organigramme communiste
est très
significative la tentative échoue mais
l'humanité est toujours diffusée
clandestinement on y lit pendant
plusieurs mois jusqu'à la rupture du
pacte germano-soviétique des articles
anti-anglais ou encourageant une entente
[Musique]
franco-allemande en zone dite libre le
10 juillet une grande partie du
personnel politique de la 3e république
se réunit à Vichy pour le vote des plein
pouvoirs au Maréchal
Pétin Pierre Laval ancien de la S fot et
habile politicien manœuvre en
coulisse la Val salue la convergence
entre deux personnages l'un c'estavier
Val sa vievala l'antisémite qui
représente l'extrême droite si vous
voulez et qui évidemment est favorable à
la transmission des pouvoirs au Maréchal
Pétin et l'autre c'est Charles spinas
Charles spinas est un socialiste était
ministre de l'économie du Front
populaire et spinas dit on a fait des
erreurs maintenant il faut on doit payer
et cetera et laaval utilise le discours
de spinaz il dit regardez d'un côté Xav
Vala de l'autre côté Charles spinas ils
viennent d'horizon totalement divers et
ils disent la même chose et Laval va
jouer sur ralliment de spinas pour dire
vous voyez ça ça représente tout le
monde ça représente la
droiteés dans le Cha consécutif à la
défaite les partis politiques vent dans
le grande majorité pour la fin de la
République même chez les socialistes
seul une minorité s'oppose au maréchal
BL raconte les journées du 10 juillet
raconte NOTAM que il devient de plus en
plus seul
mais il est seul pas seulement par
rapport aux députés qui sont pas
socialistes ça c'est évident qu'il soit
seul par rapport à il est seul par
rapport à son propre parti et il se
retrouve et il le dit lui-même dans en
utilisant des des termes qui sont assez
pathétique et assez terrible à lire il
dit subitement ceux qui étaient mes amis
mais sont plus là et donc la journée du
10 juillet pour Bloom c'est la journée
où il est trahi pas par les les autres
parties par son propre parti
[Musique]
Pétin investit il entend renouveler la
société en
profondeur à Vichi des politiciens
d'avant-gerre s'emploi à forger leur
propre conception de cette révolution
nationale y compris dans le domaine
économique une nouvelle organisation du
travail est souhaitée la dissolution des
syndicats est préconisée au profit des
corporatismes c'està-dire la répartition
par métier de la société française comme
sous l'Ancien
Régime chacun imagine en 1940 au fond le
Pétin idéal donc ce Pétin idéal peut
séduire dans une certaine mesure la
gauche une partie de la gauche reconnaît
Pétin immédiatement comme un ennemi mais
une partie de la gauche se demande si au
fond Pétin n'a pas raison alors il a pas
raison sur quoi il a pas raison par
exemple sur le corporatisme vous avez à
l'intérieur de la gauche une partie de
la gauche qui est relativement
antimarxiste et qui se méfie de la lutte
des classe tendance qu'incarne dans une
certaine mesure l'un des responsables de
la CGT René Belin René Belin ex numéro 2
de la CGT devient ministre du Travail du
maréchal et va être sinon le rédacteur
c'est d'autres qui travaillent derrière
pour lui mais en tous les cas
l'inspirateur celui qui cautionne la
charte du travail qui est une charte
corporatiste et ça c'est une tendance
profonde qui explique que pas mal de
syndicalistes vont suivre ce
mouvement le 24 octobre 19
a lieu l'entrevue de Montoire qui cèle
la politique de collaboration entre
Vichi et l'Allemagne
Naas quelques mois après l'armistice
cette poignée de main semble promettre
aux partisans de la paix que la France
va se préserver définitivement de la
guerre qui se poursuit entre britannique
et
allemand une partie de cette gauche
pacifiste se rallé alors au
péénisme Charles spinas et d'autres
socialistes proches de Paul Fort
soutiennent dans leurs journaux nouvelle
politique de
[Musique]
collaboration il y a une gauche modérée
celle qui va s'exprimer dans un groupe
qu'on appelle le rouge et le bleu qui
essaent de présenter la collaboration
comme une nécessité ils sont contre
l'idée de continuer la guerre ils sont
contre l'idée de faire la résistance
parce que c'est aussi une façon de faire
la guerre et donc il faut soutenir Pétin
parce que Pétin essaie de protéger ce
qui peut protéger ils disent c'est la
réalité c'est comme ça l'Allemagne est
plus forte l'Allemagne va rester donc il
faut qu'on trouve un modus vivindiit qui
permette de respecter les intérêts
minimums de la France et et aussi les
intérêt de la gauche française par Paul
Fort intervient sans arrêt pour protéger
des instituteurs qui sont menacés d'être
vidés ou qui sont menacés parce qu'ils
sont résistants donc des instituteurs
socialistes d'avant vous voyez il fait
des interventions il essaie de il essaie
d'utiliser sa présence à Vichy pour
amoindrir les les dégâts si vous voulez
mais il y en a d'autres qui vont
beaucoup plus loin et et c'est ceux qui
ont franchi la ligne qui consiste à dire
c'est pas simplement on le subit parce
qu'on a pas le choix mais on est content
que ça soit comme
ça
av Vichi le néosocialiste Marcel DEA et
l'ex communiste Jacques d'Orio
ambitionne chacun de jouer un grand rôle
Jacques Dorot espère porter son parti
populaire français au
pouvoir il se rapproche d'Adrien Marquet
un proche de DEA alors ministre de
l'Intérieur de Vichi et conspire avec
lui dans ce but mais Pierre Laval
avertit des intrigues de son ministre
les vinces du
gouvernement le projet de Dorot est
brisé il remonte à Paris pour y reformer
son parti désorganisé par la défaite
quant à Marcel DEA il manigance lui
aussi pour tirer son épingle du jeu ce
qui essaie de vendre DAA au maréchal
Pétin c'est l'idée d'un parti unique et
le parti unique est véritablement un
élément constitutif d'un régime fasciste
et le maréchal refuse l'idée de parti
unique et donc DAA en est très mécontent
très frustré DAA pendant l'été 1940 il
pense qu'il peut jouer sa carte à Vichy
il comprend qu'il a échoué et il remonte
sur Paris donc on reconnaît les vrais
collabot purju en 1940 à ce qu'il
remonte sur
Paris certains sont déjà à Paris mais
ils sont assez peu nombreux ils
remontent à Paris en août septembre
octobre là le clivage est net c'est le
cas de d c'est le cas
d'Orion en zone occupée Paris vit déjà à
l'URE allemande on y retrouve ce qu'on
appelle les collaborationiste ceux qui
souhaitent voir l'Allemagne gagner la
guerre et qui sont prêts à s'engager
pour instaurer un ordre nouveau en
Europe ce petit monde est reçu
régulièrement en grande pompe par
l'ambassadeur du Reich à Paris Otto abet
qui a pour mission d'utiliser sa
parfaite connaissance des milieux
français pour servir au mieux les
intérêts du pouvoir
nazi
l'ancien membre des comités de
rapprochement France- Allemagne dans les
années 30 est passé depuis bien
longtemps de la socialdémocratie au
nationalsalisme mais reste profondément
attaché à ses amitiés d'avant-gerre il
le dit lui-même dans ses Mémoires les
relations les bonnes relations qu'il a
sont avec des anciens de gauche de la
gauche pacifiste parce qu'avec eux on
peut parler avec eux il est logique y a
une nouvelle Europe la notion nouvelle
Europe elle passe beaucoup mieux auprès
des gens qui parlaient d'une nouvelle
Europe à la la fin des années 20 sauf
que maintenant la nouvelle Europe est un
peu différente de de la l'Europe qu'on
aurait faite à la fin des années 20 mais
la notion de nouvelle Europe la notion
de réconciliation franco-allemande leur
paraît naturelle et
AAB c'est très intéressant à voir en ce
mémoire n'a aucun atome crochu avec
l'extrême droite française l'extrême
droite ancienne hein je parle pas la
nouvelle extrême droite mais l'extrême
droite ancienne non parce qu'ils sont
germanophomes ils disent du mal de
l'Allemagne il ils se méfient de
l'Allemagne
en zone occupée la plupart des grands
journaux nationaux ont disparu sous
l'égy de l'ambassade d'Allemagne une
nouvelle presse doit renaître cette
presse brasse l'éventail politique le
plus large on y retrouve des journaux de
l'extrême droite d'avant-uerre mais
aussi une multitude de journaux marqués
au centre et à
gauche dans les colonnes de ces journaux
des socialistes d'anciens communistes
des syndicalistes côtoi des hommes
proches du nazisme comme
marier ancien membre du Front populaire
et le rédacteur en chef du journal La
Gerbe dirigé par Alphonse de
châteaubillant dans lequel se mêleent
des signatures d'écrivains prestigieux
comme celle de coctto Jean gonud ou
encore Marcel
a cette presse défend l'idée d'une
Europe sociale critiquant à la fois le
bolchevisme et le capitalisme anglosaxon
elle vitupère aussi contre Vichy jugé
trop réactionnaire et pas assez engagé
dans la
collaboration son contrôle est confié à
un homme Jean Lucher l'ami d'abets du
temps des comités de rencontrre France
Allemagne ceci me permet de saisir deux
autres de mes qualités et de dire
d'abord comme président du Groupement
corporatif de la presse quotidienne de
Paris jeanlucher dirige un journal qui
se veut l'équivalent du temps on
pourrait dire le monde aujourd'hui les
nouveaux temps donc un quotidien
respectable mais indirectement il
contrôle une partie de la presse de
Paris aussi et l'image s'instaure pas
sans raison que c'est un personnage
assez vénal donc il va is la haine
d'absolument tout le monde y compris de
beaucoup de collabo qui le considèrent
comme
incorrompu patron de presse verreux
Lucher devient un personnage
incontournable de cette vie culturelle
qui reprend cours dans la ville
lumière il s'affiche partout dans les
salles de spectacles dans les concerts
où la fine fleur de la collaboration
s'enivre avec les officiels nazis des
groupement favorable à l'occupant voit
le jour dans la
capitale si la plupart reste marginaux
deux parties comptant entre 20000 et
30000 membres émerge du monde
[Musique]
collaborationniste le plus important est
le Parti Populaire Français de Dorio qui
Rena en avril
[Musique]
commondanger perdu l'EUR elle est enain
de perdre pe d'influence qu'ait sur le
continent soviétique
elle perdra demain l'influence qu'elle a
aux Indes l'Angleterre est
vaincue l'autre grand parti de la
collaboration est le RNP rassemblement
national populaire que cré Marcel DEA en
février 41 c'est dans la mesure où les
françaisont commencé le REM intelluel de
leur pays que l'Europe commencera à
s'apercevoir que la France existe encore
et qu'elle a devant l'histoire future
deun nouveau droit à continuer
d'exister DEA et Dorio qui se détestent
deviennent les grands rivaux de la
collaboration parisienne soutenus par
les Allemands qui se servent d'eux pour
faire pression sur le gouvernement de
Pétin l'un comme l'autre aspire à
regrouper sous sa propre bannière toutes
les factions collaborationnistes dans
l'hespoir d'une prise du pouvoir à
Vichi les nouveaux de l'extrême droite
sont ceux qui viennent du Parti
communiste et qui vont former avec
Jacques Dorot le Parti Populaire
Français qui va être un des plus gros
partis de collaborationniste de la
France occupée et il y a ceux qui
viennent du Parti socialiste et qui avec
Marcel DEA vont former le rassemblement
national populaire qui va être un les
plus gros partis de la collaboration le
RNP dans sa phase dans sa seconde phase
disons est un parti homogène en ce qui
concerne son son recrutement et sa
composition et même je dirais sa
propagande hein quand quand on lit la
presse du RNP on on est frappé par le
l'utilisation de thématiques qui sont
des des thématiques
socialistes l'une des plumes de cette
presse est George
Albertini avant guerre ce professeur
d'histoire fut membre comme DEA du
comité de vigilance des intellectuels
antifascistes ce socialisme fait partie
de cette gauche profondément pacifiste
et antiommuniste qui va trouver à l'été
41 une nouvelle raison de se précipiter
dans les bras de l'Allemagne
le 22 juin est une nouvelle étape pour
les
collaborationnistes l'Allemagne nazie
rond le pacte germano-soviétique et
lance une grande offensive à
l'est à partir du moment où l'Allemagne
déclenche cette grande croisade contre
le bolchevvisme vous allez avoir un
phénomène de radicalisation donc ces
collaborateurs trouvent qu'on n fait pas
assez et donc ils vont par exemple
appeler à la création d'une légion des
volontaes Français contre le bolchevisme
inciter les Français à se battre au côté
de leurs frères d'armes allemands la
lutte qui est ouverte contre le
bolchevisme doit se terminer par son
écrasement sans l'écrasement du
bolchevisme pas
d'Europe ça va radicaliser plusieurs
secteurs d'abord ça va radicaliser le
PPF et Dorio ça c'est très clair Dorio
ira lui-même combattre sur le front il
reviendra il partira dans dans la LVF ça
procéder une radicalisation chez dor
mais ça va procéder aussi dadicalisation
chez
d'autres aveuglés par leur
anticommunisme des hommes de la droite
nationaliste mais aussi de nombreux
militants de la gauche antimarxiste
comme Albertini et DEA ou d'anciens
communistes revanchard comme Dorio
s'engage totalement pour
l'Allemagne
cette radicalisation en appelle une
autre le 27 août 41 pour la première
fois depuis l'occupation un résistant
tente d'assassiner des chefs de la
collaboration venu saluer une troupe de
la Légion des Volontaires français en
partance pour le front de
l'Est que
[Applaudissements]
pass pass une chose terrible un homme se
trouvait à l'angle du portail dehors et
tiré un coup de révolver C coup de
révolver vous les avez sans doute
entendu dans le dos absolument de
Monsieur Laval et de Monsieur DEA qui
venaient de franchir le seuil j'ai vu
monsieur Laval avancer encore de deux ou
3 MRE se se porter la main à sa poitrine
entrreouvrer son veston et dire je suis
touché je suis
touché ce retour au Mt d'arme du 3è rche
contre l'Union soviétique durcit
l'engagement des collabos mais il permet
également de lever l'équivoque pour les
communistes français qui rejoignent
massivement la
Résistance dès l'été 41 ils commettent
des attentats contre les Allemands mais
aussi contre ceux qu'ils estiment être
des
traîtres l'ex numéro 3 du Parti
communiste Marcel Giton c'est lui
paradoxalement rapproché des Allemands
au cours de cette première année
d'occupation proche un temps de Dorio il
rallie des communistes à la cause de la
collaboration il constitue un
fantômatique bloc ouvrier paysan ensuite
un parti ouvrier paysan qui est
complètement instrumentalisé par la
propagande allemande qui qui s'en sert
en particulier pour développer euh une
propagande ciblée vers les ouvriers de
la banlieue parisienne et cetera on va
les retrouver dans certains
journaux la France au travail ou la
France socialiste où il y a d'ailleurs
beaucoup de militants d'extrême droite
aussi mais qui se veulent un peu
l'humanité l'équivant de l'humanité
euh mais autorisé et Marcel Giton est un
personnage très intéressant parce que
c'est c'est quand même la plus forte
personnalité parmi ceux qui vont dans
cette voie-là ça lui vaudra quelques
balles dans la
peau le 5 septembre 41 sur ordre de ses
anciens camarades un homme du groupe
d'action communiste valmi exécute Marcel
[Musique]
Giton en avril 42 grâce aux pressions de
l'ambassadeur autoabette Pierre Laval
tenu à à l'écart du gouvernement de
Vichy depuis décembre 1940 revient au
pouvoir dans la station
thermale vous n'avez rien à redouter
mais tout à espérer du régime qui
s'instituera chez nous une république
plus jeune plus humaine plus forte doit
naître le socialisme s'instaurera
partout en Europe et la forme qu'il
trouvera en France sera dessinée par
notre caractère
national dès son retour au pouvoir
Pierre Laval N René Bousquet 33 ans
secrétaire général à la police et au
maintien de
l'ordre persuadé d'assurer la continuité
de l'État cet ancien préfet de la 3e
république a prêté à légence dès 1940 au
gouvernement de
Vichy René Bousquet est très
représentatif de toute une tendance des
fonctionnaires on pourrait dire pour
certains des hauts fonctionnaires
français qui sont issu de la 3è
République et qui parce que ça allait de
soi et on pourrait dire par opportunisme
sont plutôt centre-gauche ils sont
évidemment pas extrême gauche ni même
socialistes ils sont plutôt radicaux ou
de sympathie radicale voire
franc-maçonne ces gens-là quand ils
restent aux affaires en 40 vont
pratiquer une sorte de Zè administratif
qui peut s'accompagner d'une fascination
d'ailleurs pour l'ordre allemand je
pense que ça a pu jouer pour Bousquet
mais fondamentalement ce sont des
administratifs il est tout à fait
fascinant de voir que toute une partie
du personnel républicain y compris d'un
personnel républicain de gauche va
servir le régime de Vichy et va bien le
servir ce qu'il y a d'important je crois
c'est que d'abord on a un habitus
républicain et l'habitus républicain
c'est que le le fonctionnaire sert le
régime quel que soit sa couleur l'autre
élément c'est que ces individus sont
persuader aussi de protéger la
souveraineté française c'est-à-dire que
il est préférable que les Français
gèrent leurs affaires y compris le
maintien de l'ordre plutôt que de le
confier aux Allemands et le troisème
élément c'est que ce sont aussi des
ordres extrêmement ambitieux et donc à
partir de ce moment-là beaucoup
d'individus se ruent aux honneurs se
ruent aux postees aussi parce que le
régime de Vichy offre des possibilités
de
carrière René Bousquet comme beaucoup
d'autres de ses haut fonctionnaires
applique sans étatame les ordres d'un
gouvernement conduisant une politique
réactionnaire
au sein même de Vichi s'agrèche des
hommes venus de tout bord des individus
de la droite et de l'extrême droite de
nombreux technocrates sans étiquette
politique mais aussi une grande part
d'hommes s'étant illustré dans les
combats de la gauche avant-gerre si on
on dissipe le nuage si on remonte les
biographies dans les années 30 bien
entendu parce que si et bien on découvre
que la part des anciens de la liica la
part des anciens philosémites la part
des anciens drefusard parmi les
ministres de étin est importante il y a
plus d'anciens drefuseur que d'ancien
antirefusur de la même façon il y a plus
d'anciens philosémites qu'il n'y a
d'anciens antisémites alors bien entendu
les anciens drefusards et les anciens
philosémites qui sont Avichi ne se
ventent pas d'avoir été des anciens
philosémite ils se vendent pas d'avoir
été des anciens
dreéfusards donc les identifiés ça
demande un certain travail de recherche
qui doit porter non pas sur ce qu'ils
disent pendant la guerre mais sur ce
qu'il disait 40 ans plus tôt ou 30 ans
plus tôt voyez
en 42 sur le front de l'Est la bataille
fit rage entre l'Armée rouge et les
troupes
naz au printemps la Légion des
Volontaires français décimé par le
terrible hiver russe de décembre 41 se
reconstiue avec de nouvelles recrues
plus aguéries et mieux
entraîné en zone occupée Marc Ogier
journaliste dans la presse
collaborationniste est également le
responsable des jeunes de l'Europe
nouv il encourage la collaboration
franco-allemande en menant une intense
propagande en faveur de la LVF auprès de
la jeunesse
française cet ancien pacifiste
s'enthousiasme pour la guerre qui fait
rage à l'Est persuadé que la victoire du
nazisme accouchera d'une Europe
socialiste et païenne débarrassée du
christianisme qui
l'exègre pour cette réalisation je suis
prêt à conclure une alliance avec le
diable lui-même confitil Alphonse de
châteaubillant
depuis des mois je parle aux jeunes de
mon pays de l'aventure européenne je
puis leur répondre que depuis
l'armistice il s'est produit un fait
d'une importance considérable je parle
d'un changement substantiel qui s'est
produit dans les rapports entre la
France et l'Allemagne le jour où le
fureur a autorisé la création d'une
légion française contre le
[Musique]
bolchevis engagé comme correspondant de
guerre sui en juillet et août 42 C
quelques milliers d'hommes de la LVF
déployés en Biélorussie et qui ont pour
mission d'éliminer les partisans
soviétiques menant des actions de gueria
derrière les lignes
allemandes participant arme à la main au
combat dans la région de Smolensk il est
blessé par le souffle d'une explosion et
finit par être
rapatrié de retour du front ce soldat
écrivain se fait dans la presse le
chantre des aventures de ce minuscule
bataillon de français il sublime en
épopée romantique et sauvage le
quotidien de ces quelques milliers
d'hommes engagés au côté des troupes du
fureur il rapportera de ces combats des
livres il rapportera tout un monde né de
ce qu'il appellera lui-même ce que ses
amis appelleront l'aventure hitlérienne
vous voyez il y aura une espèce de de
panache comme ça autour de de de de
l'engagement de ces Français qui sont
partis maintenant ça lui il est typique
de cette métamor phose c'était un jeune
socialiste auberge de jeunaise et il va
terminer
nazi en 45 aux dernières heures de la
guerre Marc ogogier deviendra officier
de la division SS Charlemagne et
assistera dans Berlin en ruine à
l'effondrement de l'Allemagne
[Musique]
hitlrienne le débarquement
anglo-américain en Afrique du Nord en
novembre 42 et la déroute allemande à
Stalingrad durant l'hiver 43 change le
cours de la
guerre le rich
s'essouffle vivant en dehors de toute
réalité une minorité de privilégiés
continue cependant de jouir du temps
présent jean-lucher directeur d'un
journal qui ne se vend pas et plus que
jamais l'organisateur incontournable des
soirées et manifestations de prestige de
la capitale
il attire à lui le gratin des milieux
artistique et médiatique qui se ment aux
officiers
nazis au cours de nuit sulfureuse le
dandy s'affiche avec ses nombreuses
maîtresses dans des vedettes du cinéma
comme les actrice Ivette Lebon et M
[Musique]
Balin
mucher se compromet également en
festoyant avec les chefs de la sinistre
Carling surnom donné à la guestapo
française de la rue loriston et d'ancien
Truant au service des autorités
[Musique]
allemandes nous sommes en 43 les jours
de la collaboration sont comptés
pourtant les chefs des partis proazis se
radicalisent toujours plus la
radicalisation des mouvement
collaborationniste s'explique sans doute
par la marche du conflit à part partir
du moment où ces individus sont allés
trop loin qu'il n'y a pas d'espoir au
fond de pardon de la part des autorités
qui s'installeront en France à la
Libération il s'associent de plus en
plus étroitement avec l'Allemagne Nazi
les collaborationnistes qui se
radicalisent ce sont des désespérés
d'une certaine façon ils savent très
bien qu'ils sont impopulaires mais ils
pensent que le sens de l'histoire
continue à souffler dans leur direction
donc ils font partie d'une élite qui a
raison qui a raison qui a raison et
d'une certaine façon ils sont plus
antisémites plus admirateurs d'Hitler en
moyenne qu'au
départ devenu le secrétaire général du
parti de DA George Albertini reste
persuadé que l'Allemagne peut gagner la
guerre le 30 septembre 43 il célèbre les
5 ans des accords de
Munich aujourd'hui que la guerre est
venue qu'elle a provoqué l'effondrement
de la France qu'elle a plongé tous les
Français dans de terribles malheurs qui
donc peut douter que nous avions raison
et c'est pourquoi tournez vers les
socialistes et les syndicalistes qui
étaient avec nous dans ces jours de
septembre 1938 nous leur disons votre
combat d'alors pour la paix du monde
était le bon combat vous aviez raison et
ceux du parti de la guerre avait
monstrueusement
[Musique]
tort dans les derniers mois de
l'occupation les parti
collaborationniste se définitivement des
oriposs du
nazisme culte du chef
organisation sociale et de jeunesse
surenchè dans
l'antisémitisme George Albertini
admirateur de Robespierre exhorte à
mettre la terreur à l'ordre du jour le
sang doit couler en France
exige-t-il les chefs collabo kandent
encore et toujours auprès des Allemands
des places au gouvernement de Vichi
qu'il jugent trop
timoré le 16 mars 44 à quelques mois à
peine du débarquement en Normandie c'est
la consécration les hommes de Marc de
nouveau ministre du Travail de Pétin
Albertini devient son directeur de
[Musique]
cabinet bientôt l'Allemagne naz va
s'effondrer et pourtant les Allemands
dénichent encore des soutiens parmi les
collaborateurs venus de la
gauche dans les derniers mois de la
collaboration les personnalités de
gauche qui s'accrochent encore à ce
choix sont quand même choyé par les
Allemands parce qu'elles sont pas si
nombreuses mais elles permettent de
maintenir d'une diversité c'est le cas
du très brillant claud jamaet qui est un
itinéraire typique de la gauche
d'avant-guerre socialiste candidat
socialiste au élections cantonales
ultrapacifiste antifasciste et puis en
1944 en mai 44 quelques semaines avant
le débarquement il accepte de créer
germinal titre
zolien hebdomadaire de la gauche de la
collaboration
printemps été 44 les Alliés ont débarqué
et la France se libère
progressivement dans les villes et
villages la chasse au traître est à
l'ordre du jour l'épuration a
commencé les mois qui suivent le trè
Rach ne cesse de
s'écrouler en février 45 la première
armée française de de lâtre de Tassini
pénètre en Forêt
Noire à quelques kilomètres de là à
ingen petite ville du sud-ouest de
l'Allemagne dominée par son château
d'opérette s'est réfugié la fine fleur
de la collaboration parisienne et
[Musique]
vigissoise depuis des mois leur monde
s'effondre autour d'eux mais tous
faignent de croire qu'un semblant d'État
existe ler lance un quotidien pour les
réfugiés Dorio et DEA continuent de se
battre pour la moindre parcelle de
pouvoir finalement les troupes de delâre
entrent dans la ville le 23 avril
45 pour beaucoup comme jeanlucher qui a
été arrêté dans sa fuite c'est le retour
en France où les attendent les cours de
justice les principales figures de la
collaboration vont en règle générale
passer devant les juges ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que l'épuration c'est ce qui
donne cette impression de justice ne va
pas être tout le temps la même plus le
temps passe plus les juges se montrent
indulgent tout simplement parce que avec
le temps les passion deviennent moins
brûlantes et également les enjeux
politique se recompose avec la guerre
froide avec la montée de l'antiommunisme
tous ces éléments expliquent que les
juges se montrent à l'égard des
collaborationnistes de plus en plus
clément en règle générale après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale les collabos de
gauche sont à droite voire généralement
à l'extrême droite c'est très
impressionnant pour deux hommes qui vont
rejoindre Dorio et da dè avant la guerre
qui s'appelle Barbé et cellor Barb et
cellor c'était les leaders du du Parti
communiste français en 1928 représentant
l'aile la plus à gauche la plus dure
dite officiellement sectaire Moscou les
lâch au bout de 3 ans et qu'est-ce qu'il
deviennent dans dans l'histoire du Parti
communiste on parle plus de barbelleror
et bien ils deviennent
fascistes après guerre les
collaborateurs condamnés à l'eau probre
et à la marginalité connaissent diverses
fortunes Charles spinas est exclu de la
IC fot et ne jouera plus qu'un rôle
politique
mineur parmi les plus dures certains
parviennent à échapper à la justice
comme Marcel DEA qui trouve refuge sous
le nom de professeur lerou avec sa femme
dans un couvent de Turin en
Italie George Albertini qui n'écopé que
de 5 ans de travaux forcés poursuit dans
les années 50 sa croisade anticommuniste
par le biais de publication homme de
l'ombre il exerce son influence dans le
monde politique et les milieux
d'affaires nous raconter le sujet de la
peau de loroc Saint-Loup la peau de
loroc commence en
1954 marcogier de retour d'un exil en
Argentine devient un écrivain un succès
en publiant plusieurs ouvrages sous le
pseudonyme de
Saint-Loup il inspire alors une extrême
droite anti-chrétienne et païenne qui se
reconstitue dans les années
60 une société un peuple préfère
percevoir son passé en terme euh
stable la notion de mutation est
inacceptable l'idée que quelqu'un peut
être gentil c'estàd dire qu'il est
contre antisémitisme et 4 ans après ou 6
ans après on le retrouve antisémite
cette idée est absolument impensable et
donc ce qui se passe c'est que une
partie de l'extrême droite qui vit
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à sa source dans les
mutations de la gauche de la fin des
années 30 marcogier est passé par à
gauche et donc ça suffit pas quand on
attaque marcier
écrivain d'extrême droite de dire que
pendant la guerre il était à la LVF il
faut dire aussi ce qu'il était avant à
savoir la
SFIO sinon il y a une partie de sa
biographie qui disparaît il y a une
partie de la réalité historique
française qu'on
occulte au mois de février 1945 à
proximité de sigmine gun Dorio trouve la
mort sur une route de campagne victime
d'un tir d'aviation allié
enterré avec son uniforme de la LVF sa
sépulture se trouve encore aujourd'hui
dans la ville de Mengen en
Allemagne le 21 janvier 1946 s'ouvre le
procès de Jean Lucher condamné à mort il
est fusillé un mois plus tard au fort de
Châtillon depuis son couvent italien
Marcel DEA noirc pendant des années des
milliers de pages pour justifier son
action politique il meurt en 1955 sans
jamais avoir été
découvert documentaliste eff frrainé de
la guerre froide George Albertini
devient l'éminence grise de dirigeant
socialiste sous la 4e République puis de
l'entourage de George Pompidou sous la
5e Charles spinaz devient conseiller
général de corz et maire desgleton il
parène les débuts en politique du jeune
jacqu Chirac dans les années
60 en 1954 l'année suivant son retour en
France Marc Ogier rat de peu le
prigoncour pour son roman la nuit
commence au caporne après que le Figaro
a dévoilé sa véritable identité
il meurt à Paris en